there are some very definite qualities
to good leaders well one is decisiveness
if you have decision anxiety it kind of
says that you don't have confidence and
people are frightened to be led by
somebody who doesn't have confidence
doesn't appear to know the direction
that the company is going and you know
you always want to get in the trenches
with somebody who you think is going to
win the battle and so confidence and
it's very big part of leadership being
decisive I think having a a sense of
compassion is also important for
leadership because you can order
somebody to come in on the weekends and
work overtime but you can't make them
come up with their best ideas they have
to do that because they care about you
and they want to please you and and
you're a leader that motivates that kind
of passion in them if you don't do that
if you're just leading by being a
dictator or by fear eventually it's
going to come back to you know bite you
where you don't want to be bitten and
you won't get the kind of dedication
that you are looking for
you